So here I’ve got a really nice sample of
silicon, alright?
Ok.
I’m going to take it out of the bottle…
of the… I’m going to
have to wash my hands after this.
So silicon is a very common element, it’s
particularly found in
sand which is the oxide of silica; that’s
the compound of
oxygen and silicon.
It is also found in a variety of minerals
which contain silicon,
oxygen and another metal which are known as
silicates. And
silicates occur in an enormous number of different
minerals.
It’s sort of the part of science that unless
you are a specialist
you find quite boring but if you really go
into it like everything
else it becomes really quite interesting.
So this is a piece of polycrystalline silicon.
It’s a really quite
fantastic element and it’s very often used,
or in fact it’s used
very regularly to make electronic components.
All of the
computers that we use and actually the camera
that you are
recording me on now are based upon silicon
technology.
Silicon is also extremely important and the
basis of most of
the electronic devices we use: my watch, your
video camera,
and also in computers. And if we look over
here, I have got
here this is an example of a silicon wafer;
you can see at the
back this is silicon.
So the silicon is grown as a single crystal
from which we can
make very highly-refined architectures on
silicon chips, but
you see here we have a polycrystalline sample
so it is very
pretty the way that it interacts with the
light and you can see
the different grain sizes.
So let me take it out.
Did Martyn show you the single crystal, the
wafer?
Yeah, he’s got a single chip, yeah, yeah.
Cause if you can get the light coming off
it, you can get all
sorts of different coloured affects.
Here you can see, this is pure silicon on
the back and on the
front, people have grown chips these are the
Pentium 4 chips
for the computer, I think, I am not absolutely
sure but I think
these are the chips and these are the connectors
on either
side. So there are a whole lot of these chips
and they grow a
large number of them at once. These are chopped
up and
tested and the ones that worked are put into
computers and
the ones that are no good are just chucked
and so this is a
fantastically delicate piece of engineering
making these. This
is so-called 20cm wafer. They now make silicon
chips on a
30cm wafer which is about this size and you
can get a large
number more on them.
If you get a single crystal of this silicon
structure, it can
diffract the light and change the light so
that it diffracts and
bends off at different angles so that you
get like a rainbow
effect off it. It’s really quite beautiful.
A compound of silicon, silicon nitride is
extremely tough and
very light so it’s very difficult to break
and silicon nitride for
example is used in the impellers in turbo
chargers in cars. So
when you put your foot down on the accelerator
it will spin
up very fast because it is very light but
it is very strong so it
won’t very suddenly fall to bits as it is
revving up inside your
engine.
Right I must put that there because I want
to put that back
in a bag.